just a moment of truth there's really no
going back here as soon as i put this on
it's game over
the beard is gone forever yo what up
boys we're back looking
for rash as you guys know a few weeks
ago i
auctioned off this beard for charity
this monstrosity
ain't coming off until we get some one
of these internet marketing companies
up in my dms hey side note i have to
interject here sorry
where'd my tan go what what the hell
happened to my tan
it's only been a few weeks baby this is
pathetic
if you've seen my tan please report it
please email me
anyways back to the video who came
but the perfect sponsor you know it
wasn't some big dog from the
the shaving industrial complex it was a
mom-and-pop shop
a company with integrity with culture
and that company of course is
pacific shaving company guys you have to
understand
before this i was working with like a
two dollar razor from walmart
so to upgrade at this level you know get
this
caffeinated shaving cream they gave me
they they sent me
the works you know they gave me the
aftershave balm
and let me say it was a delight to shave
with these products but more importantly
we gave the money fifteen hundred
dollars to rescue america
a human trafficking charity it's the
favorite charity of the groom
at the wedding that i was attending i
gave it to him as a present um
and you know i'm just really proud
coffeezilla was able to you know do this
and if you'd like to support more things
like this please go to
pacificshaving.com you want a great
shave i can vouch for them and they're
surprisingly affordable so go check them
out pacificshaving.com
or follow them on instagram pacific
shaving
now without further ado let's get into
this at the moment you guys have all
been waiting for
pay dating apps are for sims what you
say no way
hey i'm just trying to get more matches
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
get out there
well i've got a presentation for you
today i put it together it took me a lot
of hours
it's a slideshow
uh paid dating apps are for simps
according to math now
first of all what is a simp it means a
guy hold on let's move this screen
it means a guy that is overly desperate
for women especially if she's a bad
person or expressed disinterest in him
whom which he continues to obsess over
sorry guys about that that is an urban
dictionary definition
but i think i think we get the point now
are you a simp if you pay for a dating
site
well the evidence is clear i crunched
the numbers i did the math
our chart says that uh you know 21 of
you are definitely semps
34 percent are the opposite of pimps 10
percent it is assured
and 32 it's all you're almost certainly
a simp okay
so those are the numbers don't argue
with me hey hey
look at me i didn't invent math
you know what i mean i didn't invent
numbers
ask archimedes why he why you're a sim
i mean don't bring it up with me that's
my point don't get mad at me
i'm just i'm just a humble servant you
know this is just
simple calculus okay you're a simp
now why is that you're gonna ask steven
why no you're showing me charts
all these incredible numbers but why
well
let's go through the logic here the
logic is when you pay for a dating site
you're simping for match group
incorporated
who has a monopoly over these dating
sites i bet you guys didn't know that i
i didn't know that
before getting into this match group inc
owns 74
of the total monthly unique visitors to
the top six online dating websites and
that's because
they own tinder they own match.com they
own
okay cupid they own hinge they owe they
own plenty of fish they own all these
sites now let's talk about the scam
itself boys because i know what you're
thinking you're thinking steven
is it really that big of a deal what's
what did they really do that's so bad
i'm just i just want my tinder gold am i
really a symptom for wanting tinder gold
well let's get into it match.com was
sued by the
ftc and here's what match group what
their scam was
okay so obviously there's a lot of bots
on these dating sites everyone knows
that
but what match group would do is they
would have a flagged account
probably a bot right and it's liking
people left and right and what match
group would do
is they'd send you an email advertising
that you have a match
right this is what they would do and
basically the idea is you have to pay
in order to read what they sent you okay
now match.com knows ahead of time that
this is probably a bot
but they would send you an ad anyways
and say hey sign up for our premium
subscription whatever model
in order to see this person right see
who likes
and so you'd go and you'd sign up for it
and then the match
would disappear because they don't want
to advertise a bot now based on this
they paid for 499 000 subscriptions
within 24 hours of receiving an
advertisement touting a fraudulent
communication
so 499 000 subscriptions that might not
sound like a lot but it's
an ungodly amount of money that they're
making from this scam and when people
complain this is my favorite part okay
this is honestly my favorite part
match.com would apparently say to people
hey please be assured match.com does not
send members misleading notifications
no emails or winks professing romantic
interest we have
too much respect for our members to ever
compromise their trust
oh the irony too much respect for you
dude
oh this is who you're simple for these
people too much respect
now how much did how much did they sell
out their respect for well
according to a conservative estimate i
made they made roughly
17 million dollars from accounts they
knew were bots
that's how much they made in
subscriptions from bots but that's not
all my evidence
because next i want to talk about the
guarantee scam
and this is an even bigger scam so the
guarantee scam was something match group
did
and it was their little bundle here and
uh apparently you got
you got the match guarantee you see that
guys see that right there
the six month match guarantee ooh wow
amazing now you're thinking okay
the match guarantee apparently is
something where
okay if you haven't found someone
special within six months we'll give you
an extra six months free
so you sign up it's an expensive dating
site let's go back let's go back a
little bit 19.99 per month for six
months that's a hundred and twenty
dollars that's expensive
but they're saying look you signed up
for six months we'll give you an extra
six months free
now that's their little match guarantee
but the match guarantee
comes with some strings comes with some
strings you have to know about
that you don't know about if you don't
click learn more now if you click learn
more
you discover it's not as easy as you
thought to get these little things okay
so if you click learn more you get this
which is during your six month
subscription
you must create a truthful match.com
profile with a primary photo and keep it
visible to the public respond to or
initiate email communication with at
least
five unique match.com members each month
through the match.com service
and then comply with all of the
match.com guarantee program rules below
look at this gigantic wall of text
you're expected to read that
because if you don't read it you're
gonna not get the the guarantee you know
what i mean because
this is all the rules you have to follow
in order to get this thing so you think
you're signing up for a hundred twenty
dollars
free six months no no no no no no no no
no no no
no now on top of that let's say
you get to the end of the six months and
you think because you haven't read all
these rules
these little rules all these qualifying
rules you got to send a qualifying email
all this stuff
you think you're just gonna that program
is gonna end
no they're gonna auto renew you for the
six months without telling you
so not only do you not get the free six
months but then they auto renew you for
another 120
now to show you how misleading this was
for people
okay let's look at the actual numbers
let's look at the numbers right here
boys according to the ftc
people purchased two and a half million
subscriptions here
now of those two and a half million that
received subscriptions that should be
eligible for the six-month you know
renew
the six-month renew after they don't get
a match or whatever
only 32 000 actually got the renew
so one percent of people eligible for
this free
match guarantee actually got the
guarantee
now in contrast with that over a million
people who purchased the
guarantee got rebuild for an additional
six-month package
40 of their subscribers got rebuild for
that 120
now due to this misleading
guarantee how much did match.com make
120 million
million guys are you are you kidding me
this is what these guys are making so
what's my conclusion here
well my conclusion is as follows
match group the monopoly over all the
dating apps
made 137 million dollars from fraudulent
practices
and what does it show you they want to
get subscribers
more than they actually care about you
getting a match and back to what a simp
is right what is a simp let's go back a
few slides
let's go back a few slides what's a simp
a guy who's overly desperate for women
especially if she's a bad person or
expressed disinterest in him and whom
which he continues to obsess over now
i'm bending the definition a little bit
because obviously
we're calling a a company as you can
simp for a company
but i'm going to say yes you can these
guys keep paying for these dating sites
that show clearly that all they want is
for them to keep paying and they're not
necessarily going to get you
these matches so look what am i saying
here
am i saying to stop using the dating
site no
i'm not saying that but what i am saying
is man have a little respect for
yourself
when somebody defrauds a bunch of people
like you
because they're who are just looking for
love and they show repeatedly that they
want profits
over matches they're being sued for it
if you continue to support them i you're
simp
that's what you are it's what you are
and you can take it however you want
but regardless guys of whether you're a
married man
whether you're someone who pays for
these dating apps or whether you're just
a freebie user whether you're not dating
at all
tell me in the description box below
what do you think do you think you can
simp for a company
and if so do you think match group is
worth simping for and let me know what
you think in the comment section below
guys once again big thanks to our
sponsor today pacificshaving.com
go follow them go buy some razors some
shaving cream
support the channel support some
charities
uh i love you guys thanks for watching
thanks for all the support lately and um
yeah that's basically it
[Music]
[Music]
comes along